[Music]
hey Wolfgang we just got another
Avengers infinity war TV spot trailer
and to me this is one of the best ones
we've seen so far there's only a couple
and they're not too long but they're
super awesome so let's get started
also be sure to subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date with Avengers
infinity war you're strong but I could
snap my fingers
and you'd all cease to exist
it's for in time to see all the possible
outcomes
did we win any
it's a small price to pay
to salvation
Avengers infinity war with a pg-13
everywhere April 27 just a heads up I
will be speculating and forming my own
theories about some scenes in this video
so if you don't want any potential
spoilers for infinity Worf turn away now
the first new scene that we have here is
of Thanos he starts speaking before the
new scene actually appears but he says
you're strong but I could snap my
fingers and you would all cease to exist
okay this is heavy because we all know
that if he gets all the Infinity stones
in the Infinity Gauntlet he can
literally snap his fingers and wipe out
half the universe but what's really
interesting here is that he's speaking
in present tense he's not saying you're
strong but once I get all the Infinity
stones I could snap my fingers and you
choose to exist no he's saying I can
snap my fingers and you'd all cease to
exist right now and also looking at the
background I originally thought that it
was Titan but then I took a second look
at it it's not as red as it seems and
all chaotic II and destroyed as it seems
in other trailers that we've seen I
recognise the ships in the background
but maybe Thanos brings these ships to
Wakanda another interesting thing is
it's actually not showing his left hand
which is the hand that the Infinity
Gauntlet goes on could Thanos perhaps
have all of the Infinity stones could
this maybe be the end of the movie the
end of Avengers infinity war this could
be in Wakanda and the Avengers and the
wakandans just put up a heck of a fight
against Thanos and his armies and yeah
maybe they could have proven they're a
lot stronger than fan of thought but
that could lead us into this scene in a
trailer that was released a few days ago
we see Stannis has four Infinity stones
out of the six maybe he manages to get
his hands on the last two somehow and
this is the end game for Avengers
infinity war or maybe he is just talking
about when he does in fact get all the
Infinity stones in the Infinity Gauntlet
I guess we'll see in seventeen days the
next new scene is Doctor Strange saying
I've forwarded time to see all the
possible outcomes in which then Iron Man
replies did we win any judging by dr.
Strange's face it doesn't seem like it
this actually ties into the theory that
Avengers 4 it will be a time travel
movie but in the leaked photos that
we've seen it looks like they've shown
them
going back in time this lines up because
if dr. strange has seen into the future
and knows that there is no way to defeat
Thanos based on what's currently
happened they'll have to go back in time
if they want to find a way to beat that
os-- could these two scenes that we see
in this trailer perhaps given us some of
the biggest spoilers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 there are
many things that seem to tie together
but it looks like we'll just have to
wait to find out the next new scene is
Thanos clenching his fists with the
Infinity Gauntlet with the Power Stone
in it also note that he's wearing his
helmet in this scene I'm guessing this
is right when he boards Thor ship that
has the rest of Asgard on it if my guess
is right this tells us that he does in
fact get the Power Stone before he goes
to Thor ship then we have Wanda or the
Scarlet Witch in the middle of battle in
Wakanda her eyes are red this is
probably because she is launching a huge
attack against Stannis's army but the
question is what makes her do this I
think it's possible that in this scene
something happens the vision and her
retaliation is sort of her losing
control and just unleashing all of her
power then we have Thor screaming no if
you caught any of my previous videos or
you're just a big fan and you know some
of the theories out there you know that
this is probably Thor watching Loki die
it seems like he's trapped in something
that's forcing him to stay there and
watch I'm not sure what it is but I
don't put it by the mad Titan Thanos to
be this cruel denistoun leaves us with
some words which are it's a small price
to pay for salvation this is clearly
Thanos thinking he's out to rebalance
the universe for some higher purpose out
there believing that the universe is
overpopulated or has weak beans in it
but he's clearly out there to bring
salvation to the universe and in the
last scene which is only slightly
different than other scenes that we've
had and other trailers is Thor in this
sort of Forge here it's widely believed
that this is Thor forging his new hammer
Stormbreaker well that's it for the new
trailer breakdown guys I hope you
enjoyed it as much as I did and I hope
it makes you even more excited to see
Avengers infinity war let me know what
you guys think of it in a comment
section below and be sure to give this
video a like and subscribe to my channel
to stay up-to-date on Avengers infinity
war Marvel and all things superhero
thank you so much for watching woof woof
you